[Music]
excu shedding freedom profiling freedom
to be who you want to be the district
will be hosting a number of protests on
and around the National Mall this
weekend we started off this morning
loaded the van up headed up here the
Juggalos are marching on Washington DC
the FBI has decided that we're a gang
we're exercising our First Amendment
that we have the right to gather as and
we have the right to listen whatever
kind of musical we want without being
labeled again our mark on history
it's our mark on history it's showing
the world who we are we've been hiding
under the streets for way too long and
we're about to come up top and show
everybody who we are
[Music]
written DC cafe right now and we are
watching Juggalos interact with DC folks
people that are here all the time
it's working out do you really think
this guy in a cloud thing is
intimidating I grew up like this and a
goth kid and you know in middle school
surrounded by rednecks
that's my upbringing but it helped me
stick out but it helped me find myself
I've got 15 people there right now then
from 2 o'clock to ten o'clock at night
that's the Juggalos March that'll kick
off down at the Lincoln Memorial over
here at the Lincoln Memorial you're
gonna see tourists and school groups and
families taking pictures and over here
you're gonna see where the Juggalos have
started to assemble and everybody over
here isn't quite sure to hit what to
make of what's happening over here so
the thing about following and saying on
Posse is you go to lots of weird [ __ ]
towns so it's really weird to be not
only in a city but in one of the most
important cities in the world in a place
that is sacred to American democracy and
watch for hours and listen to the
speakers along with the fans of the band
and we didn't see any trouble at all
and the Marches started are gonna go
down reflecting pool they're gonna go
around the monument and then come back
there's a lot of media here
there is a no such thing as an ordinary
insane clown posse show it's always a
spectacle it's always an event there's
always something wrapped up in it
this is about freedom is about freedom
from persecution freedom
profiling a freedom to be who you want
today was a day where a phone call I
kind of went from I think they I think
the the challenge was to show the world
that Juggalos are good people the
Juggalos are law-abiding people the
Juggalos love each other and are a
positive force for the community and I
think that's been Illustrated love
always wins every time if we're marching
for love chocolate fan we love the thing
about the Juggalo world is it so kind of
ramshackle and yet there's this
miraculous sense that all kind of comes
together again and I'm looking at the
Washington Monument you know in the
National Mall and the feeling that I
have right now you know that's I got it
it's yeah it's like a high it's like
it's like a different time
[Music]
[Music]
you